[Music]
nobody compared with this guy he you
know he was just very very good indeed
imagine what you felt actually wit even
lifting the World Cup the first honours
to do it around forth to Joe Ruth
because hearing him say that was
incredibly moving I'm gonna try and get
some more photos he might be going next
time I go back and they might be the
last way to their to get I can tell even
if I can't see and I heard the word fat
and ugly no one but me would dare and I
did not
she's a goddess one of the great joys of
my life - what - so alive I can't
daydream one of the game's greatest and
a true gentleman some of the tributes
pay to England and Leicester goalkeeper
Gordon banks who's died at the age of 81
he is celebrated not only for the
Wembley triumph but also for one of the
greatest saves ever seen at a World Cup
leading the tributes Pele who's Heather
banks saved in 1970 said banks and
achieved the impossible he was a master
of most situations in the in the penalty
area could advise players around him
wonderful organizer and you had a great
deal of confidence in him good handle of
the ball - he was pretty certain of what
he was going to do and the you know he
gave the boys in front of him a great
deal of confidence
nobody compared with this guy he you
know he was just very very good indeed a
very knowledgeable goalkeeper you know
and very confident in what he was doing
and that is all you knew you need it you
know to start there to have a very good
defense obviously the save that's been
played all day came four years later
1970 you would stop playing by then but
um what did you make of that that save
yes the same well he he'd love to tell
you it's at dinners and things like that
you know he would have stand up and you
know and it's a regarding that save that
then we would all walk out left him to
the story and in he he understood the
joke but he it wasn't a sensational save
let's face it the reaction time was
absolutely incredible so to get the ball
more make the ball get over the bar I
don't know how he done it quite frankly
it was it was a huge saver that
particular time and I think everybody
say everybody recognized it as one of
the world's greatest saves he wasn't
very tall for a goalkeeper
no no he wasn't but yeah it's just about
64 and what I liked about Gordon style
was you know which I tried to put into
my style is that it was unflappable you
know it even when you see make that save
he just gets up dusts himself down and
carries on you know I've heard a story
of where Bobby Moore actually said to
him about the same he said why couldn't
you hold it I just loved it the way did
his goalkeeping he wasn't flash he
didn't make sales for the cameras he was
just get to save over and doumitt next
time when you play for England you
playing in England friendly that's quite
pressure and quite a lot of pressure but
then you play for England in a World Cup
and I remember my first ever time in 98
and I walked out and I had got goose
bumps all over my body just walking out
onto the pitch you know and it was such
a proud moment and that's just to play
in the World Cup so he might even what
you felt actually winning and lifting
the World Cup is laughs you know he
there's a unique laugh when he when he
got when he got going and I think you
know if anybody was in line quite a
distance to him they they could hear him
because he he had this terrific laugh
[Applause]
cricket may be known as a genteel game
but it hasn't stopped sledging becoming
a tactic in the spoons the players try
to gain an advantage by taking a dig or
two firmly with their opponents
well England's captain Joe rout was
overheard by Stubb microphones
responding to comments made by West
Indies Botha Shannon Gabriel German on
the field exchanged on the first in this
series where he was heard saying there
is nothing wrong with joining us from
Silesia when protests is happening this
England cricket captain nASA has saying
you've already been tweeting about this
today haven't you giving you a
wholehearted support for John route you
say for me his 12 words as a role model
will be in the end more important than a
test hundred or possible victory
explained war all I know and what I saw
was Joe roots reaction to what he
thought was homophobic abuse and those
twelve words that he came out with don't
use it as an insult there is nothing
wrong with being gay for me stands up
and says more than anything else that
any of us could do the days that we put
our rainbow laces on and we try and
support everything about the anti
homophobic abuse Joe Roux as a role
model as an England captain stood up in
the middle of a Test match to what he
heard is homophobic abuse and he said
I'm not having that he could have
shrugged it off he could have laughed it
off he didn't and I applaud him for it
I actually had quite an emotional
reaction and the first thing was to do a
round of applause to Jeru because
hearing him say that as in a life gay
people around the world was incredibly
moving so that was my initial reaction
of course I then get into the
intellectual process of how I really
feel about this and what Shannon Gabriel
may or may not have said I think it's
pointless to speculate about that at
this stage and to acknowledge the fact
that homophobia is an issue in the sport
of cricket I always look at the top 10
countries cricketing countries and
recognize the fact that homosexuality is
still illegal in five of those countries
and I include the West Indies in that
although of
I recognize there are variations within
the countries that consist of the West
Indies so clearly there is a very
different cultural background in the
international cricketing stage and I
think the International Cricket Council
have a responsibility to do something
about that and they have very clear
guidelines and disciplinary procedures
when it comes to racism the same cannot
be said for homophobia so I think
moments like this should be used in a
positive way to talk about how we can
improve the lives of people in cricket
at the international stage and the local
grassroots stages as well in this
country and abroad in the age of the
selfie
how much does what we see affect our
mental well-being
the photographer Rankin has teamed up
with M&C Saatchi at the advertising
agency and MT art agency to produce an
exhibition called visual diets to
explore the impact of imagery on our
mental health Rankin is here with me
with him
meaning gray a head of visual content at
M&C Saatchi and marine tungee from mt
art agency welcome to you all now let's
just have a look at some of these images
which you pointed out causing concern
these are what these are pictures where
we've taken models and subjects
photographed them they're giving them
access to the app and they've changed it
themselves one of them so I mean how are
they changing themselves I mean I have
to say that the ones on the Left which
the unchanged to me look nicer than the
ones that yeah that's the idea
and what they're doing is they're
increasing their eye size they're
narrowing their nose they're making
their to face skinnier
they're doing lots and lots of things
that has weakened you as a professional
photographer you do adjust your
photographs sometimes I have yeah I've
been known to yeah absolutely
and why do you do that I mean that was
the famous incident of Kate Winslet's
thighs and I think that's you on the
front of camera but why do you do it and
well it's one Photoshop was introduced
it made retouching images very very
simple and it became a very kind of
fashionable thing to do in the late 90s
and early noughties and I think what's
interesting is that the industry's grown
up and they we don't use photos
and anywhere near the kind of level we
used to but yes it still we still get
pressure specifically from celebrities
or magazines or ad agencies to change
images I mean why are these models
wonder why do they want to do this just
gonna say I think the big change in this
is now that it's not you know the
photographers and the ad agencies like
we've said who are doing it but it's
people that are doing it to themselves
and visual diet seeks like you said to
explore the link between imagery and
mental health and we believe that kind
of like you are what you eat what you
see affects how you feel so all of the
images around you that you see on a
day-to-day basis have a sort of
cumulative effect on on your sense of
who you are on your body image and they
can lead to serious mental health
disorders we we you know I wear makeup
where you wear makeup I mean yeah so
what's different about about wanting to
change you at yours we kind of
introducing it's a fight that is harmful
I think it's harmful to people who look
at it as helpful to the ones were
personal so basically what we discovered
as we were leading the research is that
leading figures like Kim Kardashian who
have over a hundred and million hundred
twenty million photos like the fact that
they you know edit their pictures
promote a lifestyle is very sexualized
basically encourages young girls to
represent that lifestyle to behave in a
way that's not very natural and not
similarly you look at the depression
since 2010 and that's all linked to that
kind of visual content have you stop and
do it less stop doing yeah I started to
do it less probably in 2003 2004 I try
really hard to persuade people not to
use it when when we're doing sheets but
it's still something that people go to
you and also now you've got these apps
they show you what you can do so you
know they're much more aware of it doing
this could be a passing problem in a
sense a sense that people your initial
there's a novelty and you can change it
but actually you know once everyone can
do it it's boring we hope so I think the
damage will be done for a lot of young
kids that's the that's the fear you know
it's like a diet people would have
started being more aware of not eating
junk food all the time and be more
conscious about what they eat and that
has changed so why do things
change their periods that's two mental
house and I think realistically if you
are terribly unhealthy mentally that is
still affecting you and your appearance
as well so I mean there can be an
awareness in the same way okay so if
you're a young person and you want to
post a lot of pictures of yourself on
Instagram what's your advice
don't use the filters be really honest
really yeah absolutely I think that
people will get more out of it if
they're more honest with themselves
the British wildlife photographer has
taken what's thought to be the first
photographs of a black leopard in more
than a century the animals black coat
occurs as a result of a condition called
melanism which is the opposite of
albinism extremely rare but photographer
William burrowed Lucas caught this one
on camera in Kenya after hearing reports
of sightings in the area and mr. Bernie
Kosar is joining us now hello to you
tell me about your pictures yes I took
them last month in like appear in Kenya
and I heard rumors that this leopard had
been seen there and they've never really
been photographed to a high level in
Africa before and so I thought it was
worth just checking out these rumors to
see if I could get some really special
photographs okay so how did you go about
it so I heard the rumors from a friend
and they put me in touch with Steve from
like hippy wilderness camp who had seen
a black leopard and he then introduced
me to this lady Louisa who had seen one
very recently and so I traveled to see
her and she showed me around the area
and showed me where she thought the
leopard was sort of spending its time
and so we hunted around and found
leopard tracks on one of the paths and
we guess that this you know we didn't
know that it was the black leopard but
you know there was a chance it would be
the black leopard that left its tracks
so we decided to try and set off my
camera traps there to see what I could
get and after three or four nights black
leopard passed by I got the first shots
and thereafter I deployed a whole range
of camera traps in and around the area
to get the series that you've seen I'm I
never actually saw this particular black
leopard but I've always been fast
dated by black leopards and actually
last year I did go to India specifically
to try and see one and I managed to
catch a glimpse of one there so it's
been a bit of a quest this journey
what's next for you what else is there
left to try and find as a wildlife
photographer to be honest
well this leopard is still there I'm
actually gonna head back out there in a
couple of weeks to try get a few more
shots when I first went out there in
January it was kind of a recce trip and
I didn't really expect to get much so I
wasn't that prepared but now that I've
been there and I've seen what's possible
I've got a few shots in my mind that I
think could be even better so I'm gonna
try and get some more photos the
question is whether the leopard will
stick around because he's a young male
and this is a sort of age where he would
be getting pushed off by his mother to
go find his own territory so he might be
gone next time I go back and they might
be the last photo that I get
and now earlier on we told you about a
survey of young people who on average
expected to earn around 70 thousand
pounds by the age of 30 our next guest
is probably one of a few who has a very
good chance of achieving that but he did
it the hard way literally knocking on
the front doors of people who lived in
one of the richest parts of the UK to
ask for their advice on what qualities
and values made them rich and successful
he is ready Nelson and he's going to
tell us about what he's been learning
around the corporate world and diversity
Reggie good morning to you I love your
story and I can't wait for you to share
it with everyone at home you grew up
with a castle estate in London had a bit
of trouble with the law and then there
was a turning point what was it so
sanity foot work on chapter 16 and
halfway through that contrast I didn't
want to play football anymore because my
dad had just passed away and that put
even more financial strain on my family
so when I decided that I didn't want to
play football anymore because football's
all eggs in one basket I had to find
another way to take my family out of the
environment that we grew up in and
because I didn't really focus on
education I didn't know if I was good at
math English or science I said what way
can I find out the skills and qualities
people had to amass their wealth and
that's when I decided to research in
Google work these areas in London and I
made a list of places Kinston and
Chelsea [ __ ] was having you and three
other places and I went there start
asking the questions he went to these
areas and you literally started knocking
on doors and one woman took a chance on
you not only open the door but let you
into her home to give you the benefit of
her and her husband's experience who
were they what did they tell you so it
was the price family I knocked on the
door and initially she was speaking for
the intercom and said this is part of a
school project I said no I'm literally
doing it off my own back I just want to
know what skills and qualities you had
so I can take that for myself go back to
where I'm from music and hopefully
become as wealthy as you to live and
Sarah so she invites me and javi for our
conversation her husband walks in and
his name was Quinton Price so Quinton
was the head of Alpha strategies at
Blackrock which is an investment
management firm and he was just so
welcoming he took time to speak to me
was giving me great advice and he
invited me to Blackrock about two weeks
later for an insight
and I was my first time in the sea and I
really lived 25 minutes away from the
city and from there I enjoyed my day and
he invited me back for a week-long work
experience in the summer and that's when
I asked him okay Quinton I really
enjoyed my time here what do I have to
do to work in the management center and
he encouraged me to go to university and
study something finance related to give
me the best chance at becoming the most
competitive candidate so apprenticeships
a degree you're now working at Legal &
General in a successful role there you
know at 23 you could think I've done my
bit of earning a good living I'm on my
way up but you're actually giving back I
just feel like people that come up in
his generation especially from socially
Chinese backgrounds if they don't have
the visibility to say I can become a
bank or a lawyer or anything really
they can't aspire to be that so what I'm
trying to do is just give them that
visibility to say you know you can't do
it if you want to do it and giving them
the soft skills and the capabilities for
them to go into that sector and do it
so I am now a group chair of ACCA mode
and talent which is helping
undergraduates to become more
competitive I do a lot of mentoring in a
youth organization in his London called
the victory youth group I have my own
mentoring called k3d what would be your
one piece of advice to any teen who has
perhaps fallen out of the education
system has perhaps had you know a brush
with the law doesn't have role models
what would you say to them I know it
sounds quite cliche but I would just say
you can actually do anything you want to
do and that's coming from someone who
only started studying properly at the
age of 17 18 and is now working in in
the city of London so one thing I was
just saying is you can do anything you
want to do just keep your head down and
have good people around you and for me
it worked
I had Quintin and I've met many more
people on the way and if I can be then
its Quintin for someone else or someone
else can go and find their Quintin then
you know that would make the world of
difference
[Music]
[Music]
this is also a love letter to Mexico in
the time that we're living in how
important is that to you to raise the
profile and give a very human face to
Mexico well differently I'm very very
pleased that also because of the
distortion that has come out because of
the film but in Mexico are even in the
United States you know discussions about
make the racism that exists in Mexico
the Mexican sometimes want to hide but
also the fact that is a film that has
been emotional embrace about this
indigenous woman in a moment in which
there's a speech of hate going on in the
United States and a word on yalitza
Shiism to see what wasn't an actress
before this extraordinary performance I
completely agree with you this is this
is the thing that that makes me the
happiest that nomination for Goleta 12
nominations here at the BAFTAs
congratulations well yes it's not not
too shabby you are nominated for Best
Supporting Actress alongside Emma Stone
yeah that's gonna be interesting yeah so
Emma Stone and Olivia Colman nominated
for lead category so all three
characters have been nominated which is
lovely I each one of us depended on the
other two so it would have been sad if
one of us had been left out the Queen is
an extraordinary person
[Music]
I can tell even if I can't see and I
heard the word fat and ugly no one but
me would dare and I did not
she's been stalked by tragedy everyone
leaves me
[Music]
Olivia Colman moon stunning before she's
a goddess one of the great joys of my
life - what what - work with her so
alive I can't daydream oops
Glenn Close and congratulations on your
nomination and Jonathan Pryce what's it
mil this has it blew me away it's so
beautiful and so gentle
yes it's unexpected isn't it I mean it
starts in one place and ends up in a
completely different place and it's
about a complex relationship between two
highly creative people and what it's
meant in there you know what their
marriage is meant and and what if what
it started as and then 40 years later
what they had become together yeah like
my wife to get on the extension tell me
this isn't some great big fat joke it's
all real there was an intensity to most
of the scenes especially when things
started to go wrong but you know I think
the great thing about working with Glenn
is that we trusted each other and we
could take each other to the limit in
the scenes and yeah the very first
moment because the first scene we shot
was the love scene in bed and then we
weren't showing up the first day of
filming in our jammies and I remember
senior went through my head we both been
at it about you know a long time we'll
just get on with it
you